over the last several years we've seen a
huge decline in the number of people in
the United States that have no health
insurance and of course a lot of that
has to do with the Affordable Care Act
Obamacare we are now under Donald Trump
starting to see the portion of Americans
who have no health insurance increase we
have a new set of data from Gallup about
the portion of Americans that has no
insurance and we are back up to twelve
point three percent of Americans without
health insurance from a low on Election
Day 2016 of ten point nine percent and
you'll notice that that low of ten point
nine is down from eighteen percent
nearly twice as many uninsured before
the mandate and other elements of the
Affordable Care Act took place now this
changed from ten point nine to twelve
point three percent alone that
represents three and a half million more
uninsured Americans and that's just
since election 2016 and the steady
decline started back in April of 2014
this was when we had both the individual
mandate taking effect as well as those
Medicaid expansions in 24 states in
Washington DC so a lot of this is kind
of kind of obvious right if you say get
insurance or pay a fine pay attacks call
it what you want more people are going
to buy insurance that part is not a
surprise the question though is why are
we now seeing an increase in the
percentage of people who have no
insurance well it's a few different
reasons number one we're starting to see
insurance companies get out of those
Obamacare exchanges lack of competition
is increasing costs people are choosing
to forego insurance because of those
increase costs and this is going to get
much worse this is only the beginning
under Donald Trump because by defunding
those Obama care subsidies Trump has
made is going to make as soon as we have
new numbers out for 2018 health
insurance plans which is happening soon
health insurance is going to get more
expensive particularly for low-income
people so more people are going to go
without it without it now the subgroups
that are going to be most impact
are the ones that are already being most
impacted middle-aged Americans who were
not yet old enough for Medicare are
going without insurance at a more than
average rate racial minorities as well
as lower-income Americans are driving
that increase in the uninsured I
recently got a letter well I'll take a
step back
I buy my health insurance through the
individual marketplace here in
Massachusetts right the Massachusetts
exchange and I got an email over the
weekend saying prices are going to be
going way up on November 1st
the enrollment window for 2018 is going
to open and I've already been warned
prices are going to go up as a result of
the cutting of these subsidies by the
federal government by Donald Trump the
Congressional Budget Office is
predicting that 20% higher premiums are
going to be the result in 2018 for the
silver plan which is sort of like the
mid-level plan it's actually pretty
crappy I have I have a silver plan
nothing to write home about and it's
already pretty expensive and the CBO
says that this this the the premium
hikes and the uninsured rate and
deficits are all going to be going up as
a result of this decision from Donald
Trump
I'm curious and it's sort of a morbid
curiosity what my rate increase will be
I mean is it is it going to be the 20%
it is going to be 25 or 30% there are
stories of people seeing even bigger
increases predicted for 2018 and what
are the political implications I've been
saying for years that it is much easier
to repeal the rather to defund elements
of Obamacare then to repeal the entire
thing sabotaging Obamacare so that it
doesn't work well is way easier as we've
seen from the three failed attempts to
repeal Obamacare then an actual full
repeal but it's going to be used by the
right as proof that Obamacare never made
sense to begin with the right will make
it so that Obamacare doesn't work well
or works even worse and then they will
blame Democrats and the truth is
Obamacare is no miracle I've said this
before Obamacare
tens of millions of new for-profit
customers in the customer list of these
for-profit insurance companies it is no
panacea but it would work better if
Republicans actually got involved
there's an MSNBC article which is titled
as uninsured rate starts to climb Trump
won't avoid blame I couldn't disagree
with you more we have the last seven
years since Obamacare passed which tells
us that Republicans do mostly avoid
blame on this issue you have Republican
voters who blamed Obama for not having
access to affordable health care rather
than their Republican governor for
choosing not to participate in the
Obamacare Medicaid expansion so our job
is not to let Republicans avoid the
blame do everything we can to support
candidates that are running on
strengthening health care not weakening
it the way we're seeing Republicans
doing will it work I don't know but I
hope so the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership